ladies and gentlemen the U.S has been
eliminated from the uh the World Cup U.S
women's national team historic early
World Cup elimination Trump mocks Megan
Rapinoe he blames Joe Biden Nice Shot
Megan the USA is going to hell Donald
Trump reignited his Feud with Megan
Rapinoe as the former president and
other right-wing commentators delighted
in the national team's historic early
elimination from the World Cup quote the
shocking and totally unexpected loss by
the U.S women's soccer team to Sweden is
fully emblematic of what is happening to
our once great nation under crooked Joe
Biden Trump wrote on his media platform
truth that means he truth it many of our
players were openly hostile to America
no other country behaved in such a
manner or even close woke equals failure
if Trump could just say get we'll go bro
Nice Shot Megan the USA is going to hell
you know why I'm not a fan of these
these statements I'm not a fan of people
being like Oh look you know them losing
his proof and all this stuff because
they were winning before they had won
twice they had done a really good job
she was still Megan Rapinoe is still is
still a really awful person that nobody
likes uh well actually a lot of people
do like her come on I'm being hyperbolic
but she's divisive you know a lot of
people in this country don't like her a
lot of people seem to like her and so
she is supposed to represent the USA But
actively despises it and speaks out
against its history she encourages
people not to stand for the for the
national anthem or or sing the
Star-Spangled Banner and things like
that
if you're going overseas to represent
the USA you should be proudly
representing the USA if you don't like
this country you should not be in this
position and so it's I'm not going to
sit here and rag on her and be like haha
what an awful player she screwed up this
one time she missed a penalty kick it is
kind of embarrassing she loses she
laughed about it when it happened she
started crying later but the funny thing
is when she's crying it also looked like
she's laughing too she starts like
acting like she's crying and then she
looks up and she's smiling and laughing
here's my conspiracy theory
she missed it on purpose
because she wanted to she's retiring her
and a couple other players apparently
are retiring they're done they're like
let's take our early exit take our cash
do our endorsement deals we out
conspiracy theory that's an interesting
one I I don't know how that would help
with endorsements to not three-peat
because she's a grifting leftist
activist she gets endorsements not based
on the fact that she's winning games
she's coming out and saying whatever the
left wants to hear that's I mean it's
not impossible but she's already rich
too yes she I mean she's working with
Victoria's Secret she's part of their
like more inclusive lady campaign I'm
not really sure what it's about yeah
people were really mad when they picked
her in particular Victoria's Secret
bring back hot models right I mean maybe
she wants to have on her legs from
soccer so she can get in on the final
year of the Biden Administration she's
been there talking about inequalities in
women's sports pay because obviously uh
women's soccer makes so much money uh
that we can justify these kinds of
complaints
she loves herself as the face of
Oppression Henry has economics in one
lesson would fix that would fix this
problem no but the thing is she's the
kind of person from the quotes that I've
heard of her talking about how you can't
escape inequality who would say like no
I don't believe you the things that I
feel are more important than any kind of
logic frustrating we have we have two
potentialities here Megan Rapinoe is uh
bad you know she has one in the past but
how do you screw up what is what is uh
all these articles are talking about how
it's a penalty kick it's an easy shot
and she went over the net and lost
so is she just not the person for this
game is she is she not the people the
person that people should be cheering
for she's not that good
did you make a simple mistake or did she
Spike the game because she wants to
leave early and not have to spend how
much more time overseas flying around
playing these games I think it would
have only been a couple more weeks so I
I doubt I doubt she she blew it
intentionally I think she's over the
hill and her her focus is on activism as
opposed to the sport and I think it's as
simple as that is that like then she
gets there on the big stage she hasn't
been committed to the sport like she had
her entire career and she chokes when it
matters most yeah I mean she didn't she
didn't I wasn't like the everyone's
saying that the goalie played a great
game which she did but she also
completely went over the net it was like
not even close to like on target so yeah
but there was other players that did the
same thing right that's true one of the
one of the youngest players did the
exact same is always successful yeah
um but look can we just get back to a
period in American history where like
the the idea of whether or not the US is
either in heaven or hell is not dictated
based off of women's soccer I think
that's so strange to me no Clint we
actually can't we're going to hell why
what is Trump talking about well there's
there's another story that uh was going
on a couple days Joe Rogan drinking Bud
Light and and numerous times on his show
saying that's like silly and who cares
and stuff like that but uh I I think it
matters I think when you see
Megan rapino trying to represent a sect
of American politics instead of the
United States that's the corruption that
that we have to say no to oh yeah and
reject the person who goes and
represents the United States states
should say something like
I am deeply critical of this country's
history but I am here to represent those
who both love and are critical and for
all of my you know all of the people in
the United States who may disagree with
me just know that I'm going to win this
for you too and that's what's supposed
to be representing everybody she doesn't
she doesn't she hates us her criticism
she has ample opportunity to let people
know that she's critical without doing
it when she's representing the United
States when she's overseas you can have
whatever opinion you want but when
you're out actually being a
representative of the United States you
should not trash the United States and
to be honest with you this is a real
real real low bar to pass this is a very
easy ask
um you know saying don't trash America
when you're out there getting paid
significant money and and being in a
position to get all sorts of sponsorship
deals and all kinds of stuff like that
don't trash America when you're out
there being representative low bar to
pass and if you can't I don't see why
people should support you I got a
devil's advocate this because I love
Megan Rapinoe into the blue hair yes she
is yes she's my spirit what do you got
uh no I think that there's there's a a
reasonable argue to be made that like
for instance
if there was if Megan Rapinoe was out
there and she was saying we need to
avoid World War III with Russia and she
was critical of our our military in this
moment or critical of our state
department I would have been like
awesome yeah
according to Forbes Megan Rapido made
seven million dollars in the past year
oh God she's worse and let me put some
of the words for you you guys you guys
ready for this one here you go here you
go you guys ready
you deserve all of it everything you
deserve this she belongs
that's the cringiest thing ever what a
girl boss wow what do you have to say
what do you deserve
oh feminist just I'm so happy she lost
I'm so happy she's the one who spiked it
bro you give me anyone any athlete and
if they if if they keep their mouth shut
and say literally nothing and then there
it's a it's a penalty kick or it's a
free throw and they miss and they come
back and they say I'm sorry everybody
I'm sorry I let you down I tried my best
just now I'm gonna train we're gonna bet
we got your back dude we know you you
did you you played the game you gave it
you gave it you're all we respect you
this video right here what whatever it
is no one's calling it a joke
no one on the left is being like ah she
was kidding they're not even saying that
no what is what what do they say
they say they say that's a mood post
said uh here you go Megan Rapinoe
holding World Cup trophy and screaming I
deserve this is a mood
yeah okay this is from four years ago no
this is an insufferable arrogant
entitled person who absolutely
represents the worst scum of the United
States the entitled Millennial who
screams I deserve this well just just
you would never hear Tom Brady do that
well just contrast it with the greatest
athlete of all time Tom Brady well don't
don't do this to me Phil Michael Jordan
uh but he would he would hug the trophy
and he would kiss it and he was known
for being quite the but he was
just like in that moment he's he's
tearful he's he's appreciative he's
hugging his teammates he's hugging the
children he's crying thank you very much
thank you all for the support I want to
thank God I want to thank my family for
being there we all worked really hard my
teammates they all helped him go I
deserve this could you imagine
that's just great no she could have been
holding trophy being like my teammates
helped me get here and I'm eternally
grateful no I deserve dessert it's her
in particular she is particularly sort
of self-absorbed and I think that was
that's what makes her unpleasant like
you're saying a different person made a
terrible kick during this game we're not
talking about her we're only talking
about Megan rap no because she has made
especially women soccer but women's
sports generally this very divisive
issue both from the pay stuff from the
transgender stuff she uh loved the
celebrity she got from some of their
wins and used it to be the one to kneel
on the field to be the one and women's
sport needs every single eyeball it can
get but instead she's like I am going to
make the most toxic and just just
objectionable
uncharismatic people that are just out
there so full of themselves they don't
sound like teen players and it's just so
bad for women's sports and people are
just like all right I think I'm gonna go
I'm glad that like you know the NFL's
start got started preseason started last
week Real Sports God it's so bad
it is it feels so good knowing that she
missed an easy kick and spiked the game
for the United States and it's on her
and then she laughs about it I don't
even think she cares she's laughed no I
don't think she does care it bro there I
I remember when I was working this is
like 10 years ago I was advising we are
watching the World Cup and Brazil do you
remember that game in like 2013 I think
it was 2013 where Brazil lost like eight
zero it was just like the most brutal
defeat can we look down when was that
and people were crying
they were they were players crying they
were people crying as well it was what
it was just Sweden as well really yeah
they've been there were like essentially
our Rivals
was the 2014 World Cup was it 2014 it
might have been 24. I'm asking let's see
does anybody understand the argument
that they should have equal pay given
that they don't have as much in terms of
Revenue because I don't understand what
the argument is does anybody understand
it communism oh communism okay cool that
makes sense that's what I was assuming
it just makes them feel better that way
yeah I mean it doesn't make any sense
it's it's not a successful business
venture it's not generating it doesn't
make any sense it is about equal like
Equity it's about well we go out there
and we put in the same effort which
there's no way to measure the amount of
effort that they put in versus even if
they do who cares I mean
we are more successful we win more games
but that's not does it make how much
money
generally guys you guys you gotta
understand okay there's no women's
sports anymore the reason why we need
equal we know this is heaven the reason
why we need the Equal Pay is because we
have the sometimes people wear dresses
Division and the sometimes people wear
pants division
that's it
that's that's what they're breaking it
down by fair enough when the left says
women's sports they don't mean yeah they
don't biological female they mean people
who sometimes wear dresses that's it but
but for real that's what that's what it
is and so I'm gonna get in the Hall of
Fame is it sometimes if Michael Jordan
put on a dress we're gonna pay him less
money no no Michael Jordan gets paid the
same even as wearing a dress or he's
wearing pants that's that's why we need
equal pay oh God it's Grace it's true I
just don't understand I just don't
understand the the argument it's like it
is honestly it is communist it's bizarre
to me that they just make it so overtly
and all right look I saw many Hassan who
was going ballistic about this he's like
I'm so accustomed to seeing all the
conservatives the true blue the hug the
flag the shoot your guns a two-way the
Bible thumb and then you go he goes they
always root for the for the USA But now
all of a sudden they don't it's like
yeah
they don't root for us that's
provocation he does not actually care it
doesn't bother him no so the point that
he's making is trying to get people to
engage with him so that way he can be
dishonest it's not about whether or not
it's not about whether or not people are
patriotic he is trying to hold people to
a standard that is imaginary because he
does not hold those those positions at
all so it's just a communist provocation
flip him off
no
it makes me sad for all of the other
female players who are now come like
maybe it's a good thing that Megan Apple
was retiring and so there was a chance
for the women on this team to
potentially say like hey we don't agree
with her we don't want to be a part of
this political activism she has been our
team captain and dominate our culture
and made it so we are forced to behave
this way of course they have their
choices they're allowed to do whatever
they want right but that's really the
only way to drive people back to women's
soccer they have to start winning again
which obviously I I don't play fresh
swords I don't know what kind of
challenge that is and they have to not
be the political epicenter of liberalism
right now yes well there will be uh a
huge sigh of relief by many of the
players on that team I would imagine
with her gone because she just sucked
the air out of every room well because
she deserves this because she deserves
this nobody else obviously no I mean she
deserves all of this right now yeah she
does yeah yeah this is this is it man
you love to see Karma because you want
people to be respectful grateful no nice
to each other humble and she's the
epitome of arrogant leftism now to have
her losing this way yeah I'm gloating I
will glow it all the way same yeah well
and it reminds with the Huffington Post
article came out four years ago you know
women's Sports women's soccer was
performing well they were winning and
there were so many people who are saying
you know they we need to talk about them
more girls need these these uh folk
heroes in sports so they know they can
achieve all stuff like they never tell
you why girls need that also no one
should look at Megan Rapinoe and say I
would like to live life the way you do
because you treat people poorly you're
not a good you don't have good character
I think regardless of whether she's a
good athlete or not she is not the model
of behavior you'd want anyone to be like
look younger young child do that there's
another angle of of uh Ridiculousness to
this is that women's soccer really got a
head start on the rest of the World by
like 20 or 30 years so they have this
way overly inflated ego about their
position in the sport because they're
like look we're better than the men's
team compared to the rest of the world
it's like no no you got a head start on
the rest of the world because women
weren't really playing soccer or
football in the rest of the world so now
now the rest of the world's catching up
and you're gonna have to get real that
uh we're probably gonna get surpassed
yep well she deserves this thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time